thank you thank you thank you thank you
dean saloner appreciate that
hi hi I'm so happy to be here let's jump
right in
yeah well first you know I just met
coach him and he's a cool dude - and
both coach Dawkins all my guys coach oh
I love those guys wish its clap you got
great coaches Oh
that was one of my highlights yeah all
right I hope I get to meet him I met his
mom but I didn't either I'm sorry I'm
giggly like yeah all right well then
let's start with sports let's start with
basketball okay
many people may not realize that you
actually began preparing for your second
career your career in business while you
were still in the NBA can you tell us
what that preparation looked like and
what motivated you well first we we have
to understand that the same principles
really apply from being a basketball
player as well as a CEO when you think
about focus strategy discipline so I'm
still that same guy that has those same
principles as a CEO and what I was doing
as a basketball player first and also a
competitor because I hate to lose at
anything right like my wife encouraged
me to play my daughter one-on-one you
know one way about she was about 15 16
years old you know I player you know we
go to 10 I let her get to 9 and then I
got a crusher
if I was playing my mother I would let
her get to nine and a half and then I'll
crush her - I love winning and I took
that same competitive spirit to the
boardroom as well I'm a perfectionist so
I was a perfectionist as a basketball
player I did
the drills over and over and over again
and even today I'm a perfectionist and I
want to do everything the right way so
when you think about principles of being
an athlete or a basketball player it's
the same thing as a CEO I'm a guy who's
going to get there early you know I'm
not about I'm a professional today they
said okay about 11:30 well you know I
got on campus at 5:00 to 11:00 I just
said at the chapel for a half hour
waiting but that's who I am
you know and so I think that I was
preparing what I did was I asked dr.
buss I said my dream is not just to win
championships but I want to become a
businessman after my basketball career
with the Lakers and he took me up on my
up on his wing and became my mentor when
one of my many mentors and so he taught
me Laker business opened the books up to
me let me see how the Laker business was
being run day to day then I took and I
was one of these guys that was crazy so
I called the PR man from the Lakers I
said look I want to know all the people
who sit on the floor I want to know
their phone numbers and names so I cold
called 20 people and said will you go to
lunch with me
and they said yeah so
surprise surprise you know I took
advantage of my platform trust me and so
I picked their brain about business what
made them successful and I incorporated
into my own style and so while I was
playing basketball yes I was getting
ready but make no mistake about it I was
a hundred and fifty percent in with
being a Laker and being the best
basketball player I could be in the
offseason I was preparing for this life
after basketball but I was a crazy
basketball player much like I am CEO
because when you're trying to prove
people wrong
first they said I wouldn't be able to
play point guard at six nine so I had to
prove them wrong then they said I
couldn't go from the basketball court to
the boardroom and it's been my pleasure
proving them wrong again and so I'm a
guy who goes all the way in and I love
doing what I'm doing it but basketball
prepared me for the business room no
question about it you know if it wasn't
for basketball I don't think I could be
the CEO that I am today I think you
touch on some good lessons that you
learned in transitioning your career
there's a lot of people who come to
business school hoping to pivot out of
one career and into another basketball
pun intended and what would be
okay what would be your top piece of
advice for them well first of all you I
take your ego out of it see what made me
a great basketball player wouldn't make
me a great CEO I have to understand
because I didn't know business so that's
why those mentors were so important to
me and then somebody finally is gonna
say no to you hmm
and then you have to have a thirst for
knowledge right and so that's why I was
meeting with so many people because I
was hungry for knowledge and I wasn't
shy about asking questions and so I
think for me it was just making sure I
got in the right room with the right
people make sure I got enough experts in
terms of being my mentors that experts
in business and then and then make sure
that then I apply what I learned from
them a lot of times athletes were such
in our own world that we forget that you
know after we retire you're still young
and you have a whole life to live you
know I retired in my 30s and so I still
had a lot of life and a lot of living to
do and so I'm so happy that my I knew my
second life was going to be in business
I didn't think it was going to get to
this level I never thought in my wildest
dreams it would get to where I am today
but I knew I wanted to be a business man
and I would I was going to do everything
in my power to become a successful one
well you did become very successful and
I want to play back to earlier in your
career you had an early partnership with
Starbucks in around 1998
you opened 125 stores for them in
low-income neighborhoods it was the
first time Starbucks had done something
like that your stores were more
successful than the national average
you don't own those anymore but can you
talk about how important that deal was
in your career well let me go back
before that one because the actually is
a Magic Johnson theater set up that one
and I did my homework of research and
found out minorities were the number one
group of people going to the movies at
that time but we didn't have no theaters
built in our community and I said wow if
we're the number one group of people
going to the theater or to the movies if
I build them they will come the demand
was already there so I just I met with
the Sony execs and told them look the
growth of your business have to be doing
in America we got an unbelievable
spending power look at our spending
power right now
african-americans are trillion dollars
spending power Latinos another trillion
dollars spending power and growing and
I'm sitting there said wow that's a lot
of disposal disposable income and that
could make my business become successful
very quick and so they said let's do it
I put up half the money they put up half
the money and the first thing people
said oh no way they're going to tear it
up they're gonna graffiti gonna be all
on the walls and what happened was my
first theater and Crenshaw in LA was in
the top ten highest grossing theaters in
the nation and what we had to do was
tweak the the concession stand a little
bit good minorities we're a little bit
different than everybody else so we grew
up on cool eggs so I had to have
strawberry great orange soda
we just don't we don't drink just coke
yeah so
now the reason I said that because my
perk caps were some of the highest in
the industry wait a minute
so if I keep that coke just in there and
mocking my customer base
don't drink coke I'm not successful
right then I had a spicy or hot dog some
jalapeno peppers that that was the first
time in theater history that ever
happened right and so I was able to
understand my customer base and over
delivered to them and I'm gonna use that
word all the time and you students out
there I want you to write that word down
and that's over deliver because if
you're gonna be in business and
especially today's marketplace
you got to over deliver to the consumer
or guess what they're going to leave you
that fast I have over delivered to my
customer base for 30 years that's why I
have the number one brand in urban
America and so if I had to just cut coke
in there
not the hotdogs change it would have
been a problem let me tell you look
quick story about how they looked at me
as a basketball player so we're about to
open my first theater on Crenshaw and I
like and I asked the fool buyer from
some Sonia said how many hotdogs do we
have for the opening so he's like man
the same amount we going to give you is
the same amount we have in suburban our
suburban theaters we opened the theater
on Friday we sold out all the hot dogs
that normally take a month to sell out
in suburban sold it out in one night
why because minorities we not gonna go
to dinner and a movie
we're gonna have dinner where I can't
hear you at the movies so that's another
reason my perk caps were so high you
have to have an understanding of your
customer base and I know what urban
consumers want and I deliver that so
because we were very successful with the
Magic Johnson theaters I went up to
Seattle because I saw this long line
outside this coffee place called
Starbucks yeah what kind of coffee they
serve in there so I said I gotta get in
that line I gotta see what's going on so
I got in the line and you know waiting
and waiting and waiting I finally got up
there and I don't drink coffee I drink
tea so I said let me have your best tea
whatever I took a sip of that tea I said
no wonder I said man that's the next
successful thing that can happen in
urban America so I cold called Howard
Schultz CEO of Starbucks and said look I
want to come up and see you so I flew up
to Seattle and we had a meeting and
thank God he was a basketball fan and
season ticket holder of Seattle
SuperSonics and we sat down and talked
and I told him the growth of his
business would be through urban America
because you know Starbucks got it a
store man they saturate the market which
is great they dominate the market and I
said but there's none in urban America
and we got this great spending power and
I knew that it would be successful in
urban America he said well we don't do
franchisees I said I'm not here to
become one I want to be your partner I
put up half the money you put up half
the money so he said well I got to sell
it to the board let's have a couple more
meetings so long story short we had
about four more meetings and then he
finally decided to come down and see how
we manage my theatres and this is really
important to a lot of you young people
who out there you got to make sure that
what you're selling and what you tell
people is
gonna be the truth right when when they
come and see what your business looks
like everything that you told them is it
sure better look like that so sure
enough he comes down on a Friday night
and thank God Whitney Houston's first
movie was coming out waiting exhale so I
had about four or 5,000 african-american
women wrapped around the corner trying
to get him to see this movie so uh how
it comes we come around the corner he's
like wow man he was amazed we had this
many people waiting to see this movie
got inside the concession stand was just
I mean we were making money like crazy
because everybody was ordering something
and then finally the movie started so we
sat in one of my biggest house was 500
seats and the movie got going about 20
minutes in and every african-american
woman in there thought they knew Whitney
Houston personally so they started
talking to the screen girl why you still
we're here you should dump him and so
Howard grabs me out the theater true
story and said Earvin I've never had the
movie-going experience quite like this
and he said you got the deal so we were
going to we did three as a test and this
is where that word comes in young people
so he gave me three two tests so I had
to over-deliver with the three so when I
looked up I said okay we got at week
Starbucks just a little bit to fit in
urban America the coffee was great but
the dessert was not we don't quite know
what scones are so I had to take the
scones out of my Starbucks and put sweet
potato pie
pound cake sock-it-to-me cake peach
cobbler they said no way minorities
would pay three dollars for a cup of
coffee well we proved everybody wrong my
perk caps were higher than his perk apps
and it went from building three to
building 125 the motorboat was already
negotiated so when the
so when my contract was up in terms of
the number 125 I sold them all back to
Howard and I walked away with a big
smile on my face and so and he did too
because he says already and all the
interview all the interviews that he's
been able to do after our partnership he
said how our stores really changed
Starbucks brought in a lot of minority
managers district managers employees and
so and now he's built now five hundred
to a thousand stores in urban America
and it's and it's great so it's great
for me to be the guy who opened the door
for Starbucks going into urban America
and we should clap for that because
that's that's a great
so it's still about over-delivering see
if I had to kept those scones in there
my perk caps wouldn't have been 459 it
wouldn't have been that high so because
I changed out those desserts and then I
also took out the Lauren's wealth music
that they play the regular Starbucks and
I put in Prince Motown music Earth Wind
and Fire things that resonate with the
urban consumer so now if I got you
sitting there and you made your first
purchase and you're comfortable and you
got your head moving and you got your
favorite drink next to you you're going
to sit there long enough to make your
second purchase C and then minorities if
we call a place that's my place like
that's my restaurant that's my burger
place whatever it is that's what we're
going to go all the time because they've
over delivered to us and you're the same
way and so that's why you have to over
deliver and also stay in touch with that
customer base in terms of asking them
questions do you like this you like that
we always stay in tune and in touch with
our customer base to make sure we're
doing the right thing and that's why
I've been successful as well I hear you
talking about diversity of perspective
and how important that was for you
there's been a focus recently on the
lack of diversity within Silicon Valley
and the tech industry in general how
does how does that play into your
investment in partnership decisions and
also how do you think about recruiting
and retaining diverse talent now that
you're head of your own organization
well the first one is you know when you
think about Silicon Valley and you think
about what it's only 1% of Engineers
that are african-american is about 3% of
that Latino
that's way too low but they keep using
that as the excuse where we can't find
enough engineers who are minority okay
that's fine but what about you have
lawyers accountants the HR department
there's other areas that you can hire
minorities who are qualified right and a
lot of them sit on this campus too and
other campuses so we not just we just
don't want to be engineers we can be you
know we love to work at Google we would
love the work at work at Facebook and on
and on and on and so diversity starts at
the top if it's not a part of your DNA
is not who you are it's not going to
happen that's why I love Stanford see
and we don't want to hand out we just
want an opportunity I look at those two
coaches they just wanted the opportunity
and they're delivering over delivering
and that's all we just asked for an
opportunity and I tell you those who
look you want to hire the way America
looks in the next twenty years half of
America or even more than half of
America going to be minorities so the
first companies that understand that and
start hiring minorities now they
understand how to really deal with them
as not only employees but also consumers
and so for me it's easy for me you know
I like to hire smart young people matter
of fact I got one of your own that
worked for me standing up yeah Ryan yeah
and Brian I tell you what was great
about Ryan Ryan was here on the campus a
couple years ago and he was doing some
internship work for us right and so
that's when we were thinking about
buying the sparks so we put Ryan on the
sparks deal and it was Ryan's he
analyzed the numbers he came back to it
to myself and said you know he thought
that the number that we were going to
pay for the sparks there was going to be
a good deal if he had said don't do the
sparks deal I wouldn't have done the
sparks deal so we got young bright minds
like Ryan and our company and so
Stanford you producing some great young
smart also too he singles or any ladies
okay
and then once he analyzed that deal and
broke it down for for me I knew that I
wanted him because he also you have to
have people skills to work for me too
it's not just being smart I want
somebody who can also go out and on
behalf of our company represent us and
he does a wonderful job of that and so
my brand is everything to me and so I
got to make sure that the thing that I
protect is the brand see I have
everything else sustainability
I have growth I have all that now right
but the one thing that could ruin it all
is a tainted brand and diluted brand and
so I want to make sure that I protect
that brand and that's why I hire people
like Ryan who can not only protect the
brand but grow the brand and the bottom
line all at the same time and so we're
buying the Dodgers that sustainability I
have a 14 billion dollar insurance
company that I just bought or called
Apple trust out of Iowa
that's our headquarters we're going to
move that to illinois' it's doing game
busted business we're growing it and so
so when I look at it I have everything
that I want now right I have I was
fighting for first respect because they
didn't respect me when I first came into
boardrooms because they still looked at
me as a basketball player but that
Starbucks deal changed all of that
see I drove our why I took Howard's
brand it was already huge but I took
that brand to another level it was the
first company ever Jay Leno picked up a
Starbucks cup live on TV and said why
are you charging those people that kind
of money for a cup of coffee right and
we all laugh but how a show so is happy
I bow I was just on The Tonight Show and
then cost me a dollar
yeah
you see what I'm saying so we were able
to grow the brand of Starbucks for free
and also at the inner line at the other
day also being able to grow the bottom
line too and that's why that partnership
was the one partnership that really got
me everything that I wanted and then
I've had the number one real estate when
you think about fun in terms of our
urban fund so I did we did 300 million
we did 600 million our second fund and
our third fund we did a billion dollar
and then we had an equity fund with Ron
Burkle company Yucaipa Johnson so we we
went out and raised about five hundred
million so that's when I bought a lot of
the we bought about 20 radio stations we
bought Soul Train brand on and on and on
with the real estate fund if you think
about the W in Austin Texas you think
about the Hilton in Washington DC all
those things all those properties we
still own and the Transamerica building
downtown Los Angeles we used to own that
and so those are the type of properties
that we invested in and so it was really
unique and special that I could go from
the basketball court dribbling that
little basketball to having a real
estate fund having an equity fund and
now I'm with Guggenheim and Mark Walter
told me you don't have to go out and
raise money no more we manage about two
hundred billion dollars just come see us
okay and I tell you this a quick story
for some of you because some of you
gonna be disappointed I got to stand up
for a minute
is that okay
I know I'm at Stanford and everything so
all these spark people because I might
be working for one of them one day you
don't mind me changing a little bit Dean
do you okay cool I can't just sit down
all the time young people so when I
first went out to raise my first fun I
went up to CalPERS right down the road
from here and they turned me down four
times in the last time the committee
turned me down they said well why
haven't some other minority come to
raise money and do what you're talking
about doing and I couldn't answer that
question right I was up there to to have
them give me around 50 million dollars
to invest in urban America that was
unheard of at that time
and so finally I went up the time after
that the fifth time they finally said
you know what we're going to give you
the 50 million and if you I'm going to
come back to that word if you over
deliver with the 50 million you can come
back and get a hundred more million I
bought a shopping center for 22 million
it was 40 percent occupied I made that
Center 100 percent occupied I resold
that Center for 48 million took the 26
back up to Sacramento and said here you
go and guess what happened they start
respecting me like a businessman now a
lot of you gonna get turned down five
times like I did are you gonna get back
up and try again or you're gonna go have
your head down disappointed and not get
up and try again
see I knew I had a great business plan I
knew I had a great strategy and I
believed in it
that's why I kept going up to Sacramento
and finally they said yes and that's
when I took off so remember you're going
to get turned down somebody's not going
to like your business plan that's all
right you can tweak it you can make
adjustments to that but keep going if
you believe in it and if you've done
your homework and your research and you
find that you have a good chance to be
successful with your business keep going
never let anybody define who you can
become and who you are they said all
magic just a point guard no I was more
than that and now I'm proving it each
and every day Jack Dorsey just said hey
magic come on join my board ask where
I've been turning down boards left and
right and I finally believe in I believe
in him and what he's built and so I said
I finally said yes but if I hadn't
proven myself right he would never come
and ask me to join his Board of square
okay okay back to you now thank you so
that's how we do it at Stanford we you
know experience
yeah every something I live by two young
people write this down always be ready
to adapt and adjust I'm serious
market change you got to be ready to
adapt and adjust and we did that with my
real estate fund we had built some
condos the market just remember banks
wasn't loaning no more money and
everybody was in trouble right and but
quickly we said oh wait a minute we can
change to a renters model just that fast
and guess what happened
it didn't affect our bottom line we
still were successful because we were
smart enough to say okay it's not going
to work because nobody can get loans but
we can go to a renters model and this
can still work for us so be make sure
you quick and nimble enough to say you
know what I can adapt and adjust to
what's going on in the marketplace today
I can change my business or tweak my
business so make it still work you're
talking about resiliency throughout that
and I want to shift to a more personal
issue before we turn to questions and
that is your health and you contracted
HIV at the height of your superstardom
and basketball and overnight you kind of
you became the face of a disease that at
the time people thought was a gay white
man's disease
can you talk about the experience of
having to become a leader in a community
that you might have otherwise never been
associated with yeah well first it was
tough it was tough because in the
beginning getting that phone call come
to the doctor's office we're in Utah
fly all the way home from Utah couldn't
play in the game I didn't know what was
wrong what was going on and to walk into
the doctor's office and him to tell me I
have HIV it was just devastating I mean
I'm talking about I was on the floor
stated and it took me hours just to come
to grips with what he had just said
right and then what was more devastating
than that was I just got married my wife
was pregnant so now I got to drive home
to tell her I have HIV and more than
thinking about myself I was thinking
about her am i my my baby at that time
and I tell you I never thought you know
and I had did everything right I thought
you know just I I was married to the
game I put in maximum effort and and I'm
now boom this happens right I married a
woman that I met on Michigan State
campus and that I've always wanted to
marry my best friend and all those
things are going through your mind as
you're driving home to now face the
toughest challenge in my life more than
Michael more than Larry
yeah yeah I'm glad I can laugh about it
now I'll tell you but it was uh when I
hit the door she knew something was
wrong she knew it and so I sat her down
I begin to tell I had HIV and she cried
like a baby the thing that makes it
tough young people your mistake not only
hurts you but those who love you it
hurts them too they are affected by your
mistakes and here she is been nothing
but a great wife great friend and I put
putting her at rest and putting her in
this situation and so uh you know as
we're talking about it and I'm trying to
console her and then I told her I
understand if you want to leave me you
know and then she hit me so hard upside
my head she said we're going to be just
together this is the only time I knew
that I was going to have a chance to
live because if cookie had a left I
don't think I would be here because I
needed her as a support system you know
you and that was a difficult time so you
need the ones that love you to help you
through your toughest moments and so I'm
so happy she stayed and supported me and
then we got the best news about a couple
weeks later she was okay the baby was
okay after the doctors ran the tests so
I've been in the face of this disease
now for 24 years he also the person who
encouraged you to speak out and help to
educate everybody oh that's a great
great question great question we went
back and forth once we found out her
status we went back and forth on if we
should go public
so I met with a lady who was living with
a AIDS at the time Elizabeth Glaser has
changed my whole life she was dying at
that time and she told me
urban I want you to become the face of
the disease they need a face it needs a
face and you will be perfect you got to
go public it's going to help the world
and she said there's some great drugs
coming down the pipeline and she was
right at that time it was only one drug
at that time a CT and so I'm glad she
was there for me as well and then I
promised her that I would become the
face and I would do a lot of different
things to help those who are living with
it and also to educate people and she
has a great foundation named after her
and doing great work too and so cookie
and I after meeting with her decided to
go public at that time and and now you
look at the numbers there's a million
over a million people living with HIV in
this country but one out of eight don't
even know they have it there's a lot of
people walking around right now know
they have HIV and then it's affected the
black and brown community in a big way
when you think about the numbers
especially the numbers of blacks in
terms of 55% of men 45% black women so
it's really important that we still get
our go out and get tested also go back
for your results now you can get it
tested in your own home now now instead
of one drug there's 30 drugs that's why
I'm living today you think about the
drugs so much better today easy to take
today there's still a fear of minorities
going to find out if they have HIV or
not that's that's been really hurt in
our community in a big way and so I
fight against discrimination against
those who are living with HIV
I go out and educate people and that's
what I do that's this is my life and so
I love what I do I love you know going
out talking about HIV and AIDS and also
helping people and that's what I'm all
about
and then when I joined President Bush
aids Commission back at that time this
is the father I remember I went to
Boston and they had a hospice 30 beds I
walked in only one bed was one patient
was enough one of the bedrooms I thought
what's wrong with the other 29 rooms
they had to take you through a process
for you to get a room I know these
people who need a room and and they had
to go through a process to get one it
takes like a year or two just to get
cleared and that just that day I quit I
said this is not right there's people
who need rooms who have to be on the
street and we take them through this
long process and so I quit that day and
I built a magic Johnson Foundation and
we've already given out of almost about
15 million dollars to a different aids
organization we've tested over 40,000
minorities so this is what I do every
day I love it you know and not just HIV
and AIDS side we have 120 students on
scholarship right now colleges all over
the country
we built 16 technology centers and
because a lot of minorities can't afford
to have a computer in their home so we
give them access to one and so these are
the things that we do every single day
and then the last thing I just started
with magic Johnson V escape academies
because right now the problem we have in
urban America is so many dropouts right
now so we're building these drop-back
incentives the kids can get off the
street get their high school diploma and
it's so great that we've graduated 400
students
so far and guess what a lot of them are
in college right now so we should clap
for that okay so we should go to
questions you know we don't have much
time left but if you just want to raise
your hand people with the mics will come
down and find you and we'll start with a
question from what we're gonna take five
or so you know we can't just run off I
came all the way here from LA that's a
long way and not answer some questions
now
you know and my Dodgers are in the
playoff don't be blowing up here buddy
giant bang all right go ahead go it
first question from Twitter what was the
hardest lesson you learned when you
transitioned from basketball to business
I thought it would be easier because I
was Magic Johnson but actually it was
harder ten banks turned me down
besides CalPERS turned me down I was
looking to grow and I used up just about
a lot of my income to get me to a level
but now I wanted to go to another level
and I wanted that growth and I needed
some big money and so I went to the
banks and ten of them turned me down and
then I said well if ten turned me down
I'm gonna make sure everybody turned me
down so I went to the next bank and they
said yes and it's really funny
what's your name Gracie is really funny
right
so now Gracie after the 11th bank said
yes and owning the Dodgers all this
stuff all of them 11 makes are knocking
on my door saying oh I mean 10 banks
saying oh we'd give you as much line of
credit as you want you know on and on
and on but I'm a loyal guy so I stay
with who who got me here and so again
you're gonna get turned down sometime
but keep on going because somebody may
say yes
and so I was blessed that somebody said
yes and believed in me and my strategy
and believed in urban America too so
thank you though that was the hardest
thing
who got the next one oh right here okay
my name is George I have a question ad
with the equi Life deal you're you're
gorgeous
a query protester deal your organization
runs largest black-owned insurance
company in America how do you see
minority-owned financial institutions
changing the way American business is
done well I think first of all we got to
be successful that's number one you know
always remember that you can only change
things when you're successful and I
think more minorities will have access
to capital so that they could build
their their own businesses because I'm
successful and I don't think that we're
going to change financial institutions
but it's in terms of minorities owned in
a financial institution but I think what
what I can do is open the door for other
minorities I have an opportunity to
become business people right you see
what I'm saying and so right now we're
seeing that everywhere if you look at
the hip-hop community who do they credit
for a change in their mind set on being
becoming businessmen they credit me and
athletes do the same thing because I
opened the door and also changed their
mindset and attitude towards just being
a a artist or just being an athlete now
we know that we can go from the
basketball court to the boardroom so I
think equal trust will allow others to
say hey there's our opportunity to own a
financial institution hopefully if not
just again just being a pioneer for for
minorities to be able to know that you
can be successful as a businessman or
businesswoman so I'm sitting in a great
spot in a great position I don't take it
lightly and just like being on minority
in baseball it's great you know
we've changed the Dodgers we were I
don't know where we were we weren't in
the top ten in attendance before now for
the three years that we've owned a team
we've been number one in attendance in
MLB over 42,000 a night we've enhanced a
fan experience we've changed the team
and we've won our division three years
in a row so we've changed everything and
now we're with the sixth most valuable
for upset win the six most valuable
friends sports franchise in the world
behind three soccer teams and of course
the Yankees and cowboys and we'll take
that all day and so the things that
we've been able to do it's been great so
we'll see what happens in terms of
financial institution but I'm just happy
that I have a successful business and
that we're going to grow that business
we just sold another business that we
were into I was into which was simply
helped we built that business over three
years medicaid/medicare business My
partner and I Mike Fernandez we took a
business that we bought only has 17,000
members now about 300,000 members and we
sold it we grew it to 300,000 members
and we just sold it to Aetna for about a
billion dollars so I've been doing a lot
of great things and this is what I do
every day it's nice there's not being
those hot pans I used to wear and I wear
since now remember the short shorts we
used to wear Johnny you remember them
shorts man they were I mean I don't know
how we got in them things
I think it was some on this side oh that
young man right there okay you go ahead
hi my name's Aaron I grew up in
Inglewood down the street from the forum
so this is special for me car you're
killing it oh she is - let's give her a
hand - she is good
so my question is can you talk about the
conflict or lack thereof between helping
a community that you came from that you
grew up with you know socioeconomically
disadvantaged community and also wanted
to make money yourself mm-hmm
where is no conflict and I'll tell you
why it's no conflict minorities want me
to be successful right we were short
when you think about retail options we
were short retail options minorities we
were driving an hour sometimes 45
minutes outside our community just to
shop and go to a grocery store to go to
the movies and so what I was able to do
was understand what we wanted because we
were already driving to get it but it
was outside our community and what I
just did I just brought it right to us
right and minorities understanding if
I'm successful then they have a chance
to be successful and so I didn't do
anything to it'd be different if I was
the prices were you know high or our
price myself in terms of to the urban
consumer but I hired people from the
community for first thing I did was
train them to do their job mmm I would
say that one more time I trained them to
do their job and then you get the
retention that you're looking for right
and also I made it a workplace that they
have fun working at and that that again
gets you the retention that you're
looking for as well my Friday's was the
hottest place to work at and they go to
write my TGIF Friday is there you still
own right there you've been there right
and you know you man a Laker game came
on or Dodger game you couldn't even get
into place right packed right I was the
first Fridays in the nation to ever
serve Don Perry on Christo ate you know
out of high-end liquor I was the first
one right they copied my model right
and so because that's what my customer
base wanted but the reason I'm saying it
is that
now in urban America or Inglewood or
wherever you have a chance to now in
your own community get a salad get
dinner go get Starbucks coffee and using
had those options before so I look at it
as I'm putting people to work and now
that dollar our problem in urban America
the dollar only touches three hands in
suburban America one dollar touches
about twenty hands that's why I savor
the growth so I tried to make sure a
dollar could touch at least ten hands in
urban America by putting a business
there hiring people from the community
now they have spend their money where in
the community now the community grows
and so so I'm happy about what I've been
doing I'm also I was able to put people
have good-paying jobs right those
district managers are those those
managers they make good money and then a
brother like Ryan getting ready to be a
millionaire so it's going to be cool I
told him on the way here I said but man
that deal work you're gonna be a
millionaire he said okay that's the
first time you ever took the glasses off
and like oh man he started sweating
Sanford he started sweating so but
that's my also my job is to make as many
minorities millionaires as I can and so
we're on the right track already ever
I've already been able to do that with a
lot of people so far one of the people I
hired went to UCLA don't be booing she
went to UCLA Business School right eight
19 years ago so she became our
receptionist and I told her if you stick
with me it was just her and I at that
time we're gonna do great things
together
I said don't worry about this is not the
job you wanted out of college so guess
what now she's a millionaire now she's
my CEO running my company what went from
the receptionist out front now she's
making the decision so that's what can
happen and
a lot of you don't get caught up in what
job you get coming out you know you
smart sometimes it's good just to get in
get the knowledge and then grow from
there okay then I gotta have her because
she's short come on up on stage come on
on stage come on
but yeah bring the phone I know you got
handed to somebody don't put it in your
pocket yeah set it up all right nice
come on
all right ho Oh cut around back the back
I'm Maria I'm a junior actually here at
Stanford with the Michael and I kinda
just wanted to ask you you talked a lot
about how powerful you are in the
business community but given how strong
of an influence you are to a lot of
minorities and just individuals all over
the place I kind of want to ask you what
sort of initiative you are kind of like
hoping to emerge yourself in with
respect to obesity given that a lot of
minorities are you know facing this
issue and a lot of basketball players
and just athletes in general mark get a
lot of their products and they're not
the healthiest per se it's a lot of
sodas and things like that and I kind of
wanted to ask you since you have such a
big impact and some so much power like
you're saying and you want to empower
those people do you see yourself kind of
you know engaging in sort of any I don't
know business opportunities with respect
to like making those like culturally
appropriate I guess foods or beverages
more healthy per se okay well two things
first let's start with myself first two
years ago I was about 40 pounds heavier
right and I knew that I was snacking on
the road so I said I got to make a
change
so no I'm serious I got to make a change
so I started putting nuts and fruit in
front of me and started those chips and
things and I dropped about 40 pounds
right then I own a company called Sodexo
magic so we provide food for colleges
school systems corporations so we have I
do Disneyland and Disney World
yeah
Mickey and MIDI eat my food and toward
their headquarters John Deere Allstate
Insurance Drexel University on and on so
now we're starting to see now even
corporation school systems colleges they
want healthier options for students for
their employees and so on I think before
I was not mindful of what you said but
since I changed my diet myself and now I
get up every morning at 4 o'clock I'm in
the gym by 5 our cardio lift weights for
an hour so now I can talk about it
because it's the truth
you know I'm living it before I couldn't
talk about it but I'm living it now so
it's very important that we do eat
healthier because African Americans were
dying earlier than any other group of
people and so we got to make some
changes when you think about our diet
and also too it has to start at home too
you know and and then that's when I was
talking to the young men about Harlem
hadn't had a grocery store for over 40
years so I put Starbucks there I put my
theater there in Harlem
that's when Pathmark finally built a
supermarket in Harlem now we got fresh
fruit vegetables see that's the problem
we were having in urban America we just
didn't have the opportunities to buy
things that were fresh and healthy for
us and and now we're hoping Whole Foods
come into urban communities and others
Trader Joe's whoever it is so we can
have those type of options you know and
so yes I'm promoting it and I'm actually
going to invest in a company that
providing that type of food option I
can't tell you much about it right now
you know we're not there you Ryan we're
not there yet right yeah right Ryan has
the cut can i brag about him yeah keep
your eyes on him the guy with the glass
he has bought me lately about three
deals we just invested in a company
called job well that's supplying
minority talent to yes you say that
Latino recruitment I'm just minority
recruitment in general you heard about
it love it no wonder we're friends no
but Ryan has done a just a tremendous
job and if we can do me one favor
because when it's your own and they
become successful you always got to feel
proud because see guess what you're the
next one
and if you don't bless somebody else how
can you be blessed right and that's what
I'm all about
you know I'm blessed to have a great
wife I'm blessed I have great three kids
two grandchildren now but also I'm so
happy that I saw the talent in this
young man and that you guys really shape
and mold it into he's going to be
awesome so if you can do me a favor as
two people you need to give a standing
ovation this beautiful lace she's so
smart
yeah come on come on
come on man and this one too come on
so listen I came from a very poor family
some time we had the peanut butter but
we didn't have the jelly sometime we had
some of the drink and sometimes we
didn't sometimes you know it was tough
six sisters three brothers but the one
thing I never had was poor dreams even
though I grew up poor I didn't have poor
dreams and one thing I never lacked was
confidence in myself I always believed
in me always and the one thing that I
could control is my work ethic and my
work habits first one in the gym will
has won the lead I'm the first one at
work last one to leave
it doesn't change if you want to be
successful you got to get there early
you got to outwork your competition and
then get your husband or wife boyfriend
girlfriend to understand and buy into
your dream that's one thing cookie did I
said baby tonight I know it's not a real
date but I got to take you to the
theater to the Magic Johnson theater
when we get there you go to your seat I
gotta kiss the babies for two hours and
hug everybody that came in then when we
leave we got to go buy Starbucks and sit
in the parking lot and watch how many
people come into the store
that's gonna be our date but guess what
she was sitting right there with me the
hard work paid off five championships
led the Lakers to nine finals in 12
years what a run right then here the
business world now I was struggling to
get money in capital now I don't have to
worry if I need to raise a billion
dollars tomorrow which was starting a
new fund I wish I could tell you about
it but we are already got two billion
committed we haven't even gone out
because I got a proven track record I'm
gonna okay god bless you
you